an eleven-year-old amputee has just
received an r2d2 style bionic arm
Bella Tadlock is a huge Star Wars fan
the Florida girl wanted to be just like
Luke Skywalker who famously got his own
Bionic hand not only did she get her
wish she even got a chance to show it
off as someone really special
[Applause]
just this morning my daughter Chelsea
was showing me the video of you with
your r2d2 arm and you're the first
person to get one of those aren't you I
mean 77 that is Luke Skywalker himself
actor Mark Hamill heard Tadlock story on
Twitter and he reached out to her and at
the end he told her amazing ways he not
only she was raising money for that arm
he retweeted her tweet to to his
millions of followers which helped her
raise money yeah I hope in the future
that that kind of thing is just normal
is gonna be like a pair of glasses yeah
alarm / glassing same thing I know Bobbi
said my daughter Chelsea told me there's
somebody who lives in a galaxy so far
far away alright thanks